Oh,
hello, everybody.
Hi, hi, hi.
Oh, hi, hi.
Hi, hi.
We return to the island, baby.
Hello, hello, again.
Hello, hello, hello.
Welcome to Jurassic Park.
Sorry, I didn't know that was going to happen.
I was about to start singing the song.
Is this game scary?
No, maybe.
Did you think original Jurassic Park was scary?
Well, actually, no.
The book is, like, an actual horror novel.
They've action-fied Jurassic Park, but the book?
The book is, like, actual horror.
Look at the little thing in the amber, and then you take the DNA.
Hey.
Whoa!
Yeah!
Clone, clone, clone!
I was a small child, so yes.
My niece told me to tell you your cue.
That's... it's actual size compared to a quarter.
No!
I... Also, there will be sound.
There will be.
I just gotta put the credits in.
I gotta... I got my quarters ready.
I got my quarters ready!
Um, what was I saying?
Uh...
I'm gonna lower myself a little bit.
You know, I...
So, I'm... my...
So, here, bring my quarter down, too.
Okay, there we go.
Sorry, the game, like, pauses when I...
Okay, look at the raptors!
Um...
Yeah.
I was like, you know what?
I kinda wanna play...
Jurassic Park arcade game.
I don't know why.
I just thought about it, you know?
And, um...
I got...
I'm being...
I'm...
Oh!
I'm playing with my...
With my trusty...
Uh...
Controller here.
So...
Um...
Yeah!
And...
Oh, I forgot to say...
Your niece!
Thank you.
I'm...
I'm fluttering my eyelashes.
Yeah!
No light gun.
I actually...
In my research, learned that this game did not have a light gun.
This game...
I used a...
Uh...
Oh, gosh.
My brain.
Sorry.
I have a...
I have such a bad headache today.
Um...
A joystick!
Yeah, it was a joystick!
So, I was thinking...
And I was like, oh, I really wanna use, like, my 3D model.
For, like, some sort of arcade game in the future.
I was thinking maybe...
Um...
Maybe, like, Time Crisis.
Or something like that.
You know?
Hmm.
How was New York?
Oh, my gosh!
Thanks for asking!
Oh, my gosh, you guys.
I went to New York City.
For one day.
I went to New York City for one day.
I literally...
I woke up at 4 a.m.
I went to the airport.
Possessed a person.
Boarded the aircraft.
I...
Got there.
And why was I there?
You might ask.
I was there for the Metal Gear Solid Delta pop-up!
Yeah!
Yeah, I went and...
I met up with some friends there.
So, at first, I was like, I don't think I will go because I'm scared of New York.
And then all my friends were like, I'll be there.
I'll be there.
And I was like, okay, I'll go, I'll go.
And so, I went and...
Oh, my gosh, you guys.
It was so...
So, it was like a little pop-up where they were selling some merch.
And then also, you could play a demo of the game if you...
If you...
Got a ticket for that.
But also, they were like, letting anybody...
If there was space, they were letting anybody play the game.
So, you really didn't even need to get a ticket.
Thank you, guys, for all this.
Thank you.
Happy birthday.
Happy, happy birthday.
Did you show up and kept your wording, huh?
It was...
Did you get a chance?
Yeah, I did.
I...
They let me play walking in off the street.
No, si, si.
And so, I have already played it.
I had already played it at Tokyo Game Show last year.
But the demo went a little bit longer this time.
And before it went up to Sokolov.
But then this one was Virtuous Mission.
Which they did not tell me.
I actually...
I sped through everything.
I did...
Everybody else is like, Hmm, I'm going to see how shooting feels.
And how the guard's AI acts.
Hmm, I'm going to be all technical, me.
I was like, show me that ocelot.
I was like, I was like, let me get to ocelot.
Let me...
Let me get to ocelot.
And so, I zoomed everything.
I went pow, pow, pow to each guard.
I went boom, boom, boom.
Run, run, run.
I got to...
And the ocelot scene was the only cutscene.
I was...
Oh my gosh.
I was literally shaking.
My legs would not...
I could not control myself.
But I was by myself when I was doing the...
So I had to control my...
Oh my god.
I'm getting excited again.
Okay.
I had...
I had tears in my eyes.
You guys don't understand.
I was...
Oh my god.
I pulled that.
I gotta stop thinking about it.
And...
And then I got through it.
And I was like, okay, well...
This was fun.
I'll just keep going.
And I get to...
I get through Snake...
I start Snake Eater.
And I'm like, la la la.
Okay, now I'll actually like...
Play the game.
And like, look around.
And do things.
And...
And some...
Someone came up to me and like...
Tapped me on the shoulder.
And they were like...
Okay, you're done.
And I was like...
Wait, what do you mean?
Well...
Huh?
They...
I...
At first I thought she said like...
Oh, sorry.
Like...
Something...
She said...
I couldn't understand.
I was like...
Oh, sorry.
She said something.
And I was like...
Oh.
No, I just got to this part.
And she was like...
No, no.
We have to kick you out.
It's only...
Well, she didn't say that.
But...
She was like...
It's only...
It's only Virtuous Mission.
You can play up to.
You can't...
You can't start snake-eating him.
I was like...
Oh...
So...
Yeah...
Join us here today.
The world record holder of Delta Demo Masala.
Percent.
Yeah...
So I got kicked out...
A little early...
I was like...
Oh man...
I just want to like...
Now actually...
Do the controls and stuff.
Hmm.
But...
It was good.
It was good, good.
Yes, yes.
Virtual Mission.
But the pop-up itself was like...
Oh my gosh.
Like I said...
It was so beautiful.
The venue was so...
Oh my gosh.
They did such an incredible job with the decorating and everything.
And...
Um...
My friend Maddie...
Oh, that's Raspberry.
She was there.
I got to hang out with her.
And I really love her.
So I'm really happy.
And...
Um...
Me and my friend...
We were being really obnoxious.
We were like...
Oh my god.
It's stag.
And I brought so many little toys and trinkets...
Because I wanted to get a million pictures.
Which I did.
Uh...
Yeah, my Oshikots.
Yeah.
And I was like...
Stag!
On the wall.
And...
I look to my...
I look...
I look over and...
Uh...
There was...
Sea Dog Connor.
Watching my friend and I.
And I was like...
Oh no.
And...
And I was like...
Oh...
Hello.
I'm...
I'm Mint Phantom.
And he was like...
Yeah, I know.
Oops.
Whoopsie.
I made a fool of...
In front of that guy.
And also in front of the creative director of Delta.
So...
Yeah.
I hope they...
I hope the director felt my passion.
But he gave me a free t-shirt.
That was really nice of him.
So...
Yeah.
He's like one of the...
He was a guy that like...
Helped make the pop-up happen.
So...
Yeah, I got a free shirt.
Yippee.
It was really, really nice.
And...
Oh my gosh.
I don't know if you guys saw the pictures from the pop-up.
But I definitely posted on...
And don't worry.
We're gonna get to the game.
Like really soon.
Sorry.
I'm yapping.
I posted pictures.
And you can see the room has like...
The projection on all the walls.
And then also...
There's the flowers.
There's the flowers in the room.
I learned that those flowers...
Those...
Those were custom made.
They...
They went out of their way to get the exact flower made for the event.
So that it wouldn't just be like white flowers.
Like it was...
It was...
The actual...
I was like...
Holy moly.
Like that's...
That's some incredible...
Oh my gosh.
I'm still so...
I'm not over it.
I'm so not over it.
Yeah.
The detail was just really, really impressive to me.
So...
Bill, thank you so much for the...
Thank you.
Got caught being herself again.
My friend, she went in first for the playthrough.
And I saw her afterwards.
And that's when she told me.
She was like...
You...
You can get to the ocelot part.
And I was like...
So that's what motivated me.
Because I thought it was going to be the same as like with TGS.
But no.
It was apparently the whole...
The whole entire game.
The whole game at my fingertips.
And I couldn't play it.
And it's killing me.
It's killing me.
Mintosaurus Rex.
Sounds like MGS Nerd Heaven.
It really was.
And it was so great.
Nier fans.
MGS fans.
Crying over a field of white flowers.
Thank you for the vibe gifted.
It was really nice.
Everybody was like wearing Metal Gear shirts.
And...
There were some cosplayers.
There were official cosplayers.
Like I saw a cosplayer.
Paramedic even.
I was like...
Oh my gosh.
I saw a cosplayer of the boss.
There was like a snake cosplayer.
He looked really good.
I did not get to meet him.
Thank God.
Because...
I would be...
I would be acting like a fool.
And...
Um...
Oh my gosh.
And then afterwards...
Uh...
I went to Federal Hall.
I got to do a little bit of Oshikats.
MGS2 Oshikats.
And I went to Federal Hall.
And it was so smelly.
Gosh.
New York is such a stinky city.
Um...
I woke up this morning.
And I was like...
Oh my throat.
Did I get sick?
No.
I think it was just the air there.
It was gross.
Those weren't cosplayers.
They were New Yorkers.
What are you talking about?
Your love for MGS has caused me to buy the Master Collection via two copies of four.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
It was really stinky.
But...
I was like...
Oh my gosh.
That's where Solidus died.
And oh my gosh.
That's where...
That's where Snake was standing.
Oh, this is where all the people walked in Slough Motion.
My president died up there.
Oh my...
And Raiden.
And that's where Raiden threw his dog tag away.
I was...
I was just being a silly goofball.
I also got to see the Chrysler Building and the Empire State Building.
And I was like...
I was like...
I pointed to the Chrysler Building and I was like, that's what King Kong climbed.
And I was just waiting for some nerd to come up and be like, um...
Actually, it was the Empire State Building.
And I could prove it.
And then King Kong all night.
Woo!
So, it was a lot of fun.
And...
And then I went home.
And I just was there for one day.
And that was it.
I went just for that.
And then I...
Then I was...
Then I'm back and I'm here.
Yeah.
So...
Jane, happy birthday!
Sorry, I missed it.
Even though it was yesterday.
I'm sorry.
I was in New York.
Hot dog!
Hot dog.
Yeah, I've never done that before.
Where it was like a...
A day trip kind of thing.
Like where I get in and then leave.
I've never done anything like that before.
It was...
It was very...
I think that's why I have a headache today.
In fact, I might actually go get some medicine.
If you guys will let me.
Minto cosplaying as Rose.
Gonna cry about empty rooms.
I wanted to be like...
I wanted to be that...
The tourist.
That's just like...
Um, excuse me.
Which...
Which one of those buildings did King Kong climb?
And then some...
Some cute lady goes...
Oh, it's the Chrysler building, I think.
And then I wanted to watch it happen.
I wanted to watch the meet cute.
I wanted to watch them be like...
Um, no, actually.
It was epic.
And then I'm just sitting there like...
It's happening.
It's happening right now in my head.
Whew.
Okay.
I'm gonna go get some...
A headache medicine.
Um, do you guys wanna listen to the song?
Actually, it's really annoying.
Okay, hold on.
Let me put on some music at least.
Wah!
Raptor attack.
Uh, uh, uh.
Na-na-na.
Na-na-na-na.
Na-na.
Sorry, guys.
I'm gonna be like...
One second.
The special April 30th tour.
It was so cool, too.
Though, walking around...
I felt like I was in Metal Gear.
And then I saw the bridge.
And I was like...
Hudson River.
Sorry.
Okay, sorry.
Okay.
Give me one second to go get some medicine.
Uh, you can keep watching.
BRB!
Ugh.
Oh my gosh.
I'm back.
Sorry.
Ugh.
It's...
Sorry.
Ugh.
Migraines suck.
I even just talked about how I don't get migraines very much anymore.
Damn!
It's it.
Thank you so much for the 50-50.
Thank you.
Ah.
Okay.
Ooh.
Rev up that Botox.
I did jinx it, huh?
I did.
Anyways.
I saw someone say...
Natsukashii BGM, right?
Whoa.
Zach, thank you so much for the 50.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Holy cow.
Why?
Why so many you gifted today?
All right.
I have to warn you guys.
I didn't adjust the volume yet.
So I don't know if it's too loud or not.
Seeing you gush about Metal Gear has made me decide to replay the Pagetor.
Whoa.
Nice.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Really?
Yesterday just reignited everything that I love about the series.
For real.
Very loving this retro Mito video game arc.
I know.
Recently, I've just been only doing retro games, huh?
Yeah.
And here we have the Ghost VTuber at its natural environment.
A Konami promotional event for Metal Gear game.
Thank you for the super test.
Thank you.
King Kong Riot.
That's me.
I'm causing the riot.
Look at the paused image.
Sorry.
I'm a little hyper today because I'm so excited about yesterday still.
But also, today will be a lot of fun.
And this game...
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
Oh, hold on.
If I get too excited, it hurts so bad.
But I can't stop getting excited.
I think I...
Oh, okay.
Okay.
The title's music for this is really, really obnoxious.
But we're gonna make it.
I believe.
Even if I need a million quarters, we'll make it.
I'm gonna start with five quarters.
And then we'll go from there.
But I'm confident.
If I have to get more quarters, I will.
Okay?
If I have to get more quarters, I'll just go get more quarters.
Alright.
Oh.
Did my...
Thing disconnect?
There it is.
Good luck.
Maybe we'll start with three.
This is so annoying.
It is like the dandaran.
Okay.
Ikimasu!
And then...
Jurassic Park!
Sorry, player two.
You don't get to play.
Area one, baby.
Area one.
When's the T-Rex come out?
Ah!
Right there!
Oh, he's shaking!
Ah!
Shoot the head!
I'm shooting.
Oh my gosh.
I'm actually so stable.
Oh.
Only...
Oh my god.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh gosh.
She's getting real close to me.
One dino...
Nevermind.
I was gonna say one dino down.
Is this the head?
I'm already at half health.
Yeah!
Uh-oh.
Oh, shoot.
Uh, shoot.
Shoot.
I got some health.
There's-there's-there's raptors everywhere and rocks!
Oh my god!
I can't see anything!
Why?
Why is the music like... What's
the sensitivity?
Crazy.
It automatically, like, goes... Oh gosh!
Goes back to the middle like that, you see?
So it's a little tough.
Oh!
Out of the way!
Out of the... Guys.
Not the Triceratops!
I think we made them angry!
I think we made them mad!
Oh my god.
Where?
This is insane.
Oh gosh!
Oh god!
Oh no!
I'm gonna die!
Oh my god!
No, no, no!
Please, no!
Oh my gosh!
I'm in danger!
Uh-oh.
I'm in danger.
Guys... I have to go ask for another corridor.
I have to go ask for another corridor.
Oh my god!
Wait!
I forgot something.
One second.
Wait!
One second!
So I asked my mom for more money and she said you gotta do chores.
For more money.
So I can't... I can't... I can't do anything until I wash the dishes.
Because my mom will give you a quarter.
No!
Okay, okay.
Alright.
This is easy peasy.
Oh.
I'm washing.
Go away.
It's clean enough.
Okay.
Next.
The Covenant Corner!
Thanks, Mom!
Oh.
Uh.
Wait, where am I?
Oh.
The
Covenant Corner.
Okay.
Are you guys ready?
Let's keep going.
Oh.
Oh shoot.
How do I shoot?
Shoot.
I didn't miss a spot.
Ah!
I thought that we were done here!
Oh my gosh.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Oh god, no!
Oh my god.
I don't want to shoot the triceratops though.
They're so cute.
Why did they attack me?
Aren't you guys so...
I'll give you... I'll give you a start...
One of those leaves.
That's really popular.
Oh, did we make it?
Oh, there's some health.
Let's go.
Oh, maybe I should grab...
Oh!
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Since when?
Guys, I'm in danger.
Guys!
Guys, I have to go ask for another quarter.
Guys,
so I asked my mom for another quarter and she said, get a job.
So, today, I sell lemonade.
Lemonade here!
Lemonade!
25 cents, one quarter.
Get your lemonade!
Lemonade!
Just 25 cents for your lemonade!
La-da-da-da!
Oh!
Hello, sir!
Would you like a nice, cold, tall glass of lemonade?
Oh!
Yeah.
I'll take it.
Okay.
Oh, hold on.
Yes sir, that'll be 25 cents.
There you are.
Thanks a lot.
It looks delicious.
Okay.
Okay guys, we got our quarter.
Let's go back to the arcade.
I got another quarter.
Okay!
We can do this!
I believe!
I forgot the quarter.
No, it's right here on my head.
Don't worry.
Don't worry about it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, this part is... How am I supposed to avoid this?
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm doing it.
I'm killing him.
Wait, how am I supposed to do this?
Oh my god, it's too difficult.
The island of lemonade.
So I only sold...
Oh please!
Please!
Guys...
We have to go ask for another quarter.
I
think we have to go ask for another quarter.
Your mom is being kind of stingy.
Oh no, no, don't worry about it.
Okay.
Okay, let's go ask for another quarter.
Ah, yes.
New York City.
I just... I just... I was just here, Times Square.
Actually, I didn't go to Times Square.
Well, but you know what you learn from Times Square?
It's that...
It's that anybody can be scammed at Times Square.
All you have to do is have the right act.
And me, I know exactly what to do.
I'm Elmo.
And today, I'm going to sing on the street for cash money.
If you see me, if you look me in the eyes, you have to give me a quarter.
It's the rules.
It's the rules of... of Times Square.
Okay.
I will sing... I will sing now.
Is it going to play?
I will sing now.
Here's a room.
Dram!
Last Ruby Lube.
Yorby tensile double dubs.
Imi dook a mini shoops.
Sippy keeps a upper goop.
Last Ruby Lube.
Yorby makes a crappy car.
In a kitty tar-y tar.
To be hip-double-ay-ar.
Last Ruby Lube.
Ima stick a in a bar.
Ski-bi-di-mi-mi-na-yar.
In a hana-show-a-tar.
Last Ruby Lube.
Yor-ma-tinka-buki-yaw.
Aw-i-si-ba-guna-stow.
Aw-aw-aw-aw.
Babs-si-l-fubi-noob.
Do-bi-a-ta-quep.
Na-si-ba-fubi-noob.
Topi-nook-on-sker-dox.
Do-na-waka-dama-babs.
Tinka-si-bi-do-na-ka.
Tum-ba-lu-i-i-sa-fla.
Rampi-fer-va-perba-dates.
Pura-ru-fa-mona-rex.
Tinka-ni-ni-di-berbe-to-de-f.
Frin-chi-dub-le-bs-ni-i-bi-up-u-plai-m-a-s-goo.
Oh, well, it's a burp to burp.
I'm a pip-tee-snur-z-a-roo.
Well, last ruby-noob.
You're a dance-o-double-doop.
Skimmy-doo-ka-mimmy-shoop.
Sippy keeps off her goop.
Last ruby-noob.
Don't forget the quarters.
You can put them in my hands.
Oh, oh, wow.
Last ruby-noob.
I'm a sick-a-in-a-par.
Sippy-dippy-min-a-yor.
In-a-ha-na-show-a-tar.
That's ruby-noob.
Yarm-a-tinka-buki-yaw.
Aw-a-siba-go-na-stow.
Aw, aw, wow.
Laps-i-da-fruba-noob.
Dooby-a-da-queb.
Oh, thank you very much, reporters.
That's ruby-noob.
T-G-I-F-T.
G-I-F-T.
Laps-ruba-noob.
Yarm-a-dans-o-double-doops.
E-me-dooc-a-me-me-shoops.
Sippy keeps off her goop.
Laps-ruba-noob.
Yarm-a-mex-a-crappy-car.
In-a-kitty-do-y-ar.
So heap-double-y-ay-ar.
Laps-ruba-noob.
Y-me-a-sik-a-in-a-par.
Ski-pi-dibi-mi-na-yor.
Laps-ruba-noob.
Yarm-a-ting-kambuki-yaw.
Aw-a-sima-gones-taw.
Aw-aw-aw-aw.
Apsie-dap-rooby-doop.
Doobie-oh!
Oh.
I got my quarter!
Nice.
Alright.
I hope I don't need any more quarters.
Okay.
Alright.
Might have to bring Elmo back out.
So... Alright.
Insert chord.
Here we go!
Oh my god.
It's so loud.
There we go.
Okay.
How do I defeat these guys?
Oh, I shoot them here!
Oh my gosh.
In the sky.
Okay, okay.
Before they come after me.
Oh, they're coming close.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Is this supposed to happen?
Wait.
What's happening?
Don't worry, guys.
The last one is not as bad.
As Elmo.
Okay.
I'm gonna go get my quarter.
So I asked my mom again.
For a quarter.
And, um... She said, you know, you gotta do more chores.
Okay?
So... Here we are, everybody.
We are... We are... Mowing the lawn.
Let's mow the lawn together!
It's pretty... Whoa.
It's much bigger than I expected.
Done.
We are...
We are... We are... We are... We are... We are...
We are... We are...
We are...
We are
And this is the second one.
I
think we're all good.
Oh my goodness gracious.
Oh wait, I forgot to come back.
Oh my gosh, I'm all hot and sweaty now.
Okay, let's beat this game, right?
Yeah, thanks for the quarter, Mom, and everybody else.
Thanks for the quarters.
I think I got sunburned even, look at me.
Oh my gosh, I didn't expect that I would be mowing the lawn today.
Alright, let's keep going.
Okay, I gotta get the trees though, no?
Oh, no?
We're good?
What is this?
Oh, we're blowing up cars now.
These could be a means of escape, no?
Wait, why is it caution?
Oh my gosh.
These guys, again.
Please, please wear some health.
Please wear some health, no!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
This is so hard.
Why is this game so hard?
Guys...
Um... I... I'm... Okay, hold on.
Let me... Hold on, one moment.
I'm
gonna look under the, uh... The machine to see if, um...
If anybody... If anybody's dropped any quarters, you know?
Oh, no!
Found one!
I found one under the machine!
How lucky is that?
Yippee!
Okay, we continue.
Oh my gosh, please, please, please!
Ow!
God!
This game!
I'm getting the... I'm getting the... The vines and the... The cautions and everything!
Oh my gosh!
We're only on area two?
Oh shoot.
Oh no!
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch.
Please go away!
Guys,
I'm totally out of my bit, actually.
I thought we were on area two.
Um... I miscalculated... A little bit.
Oh my god, there's feet!
Ah!
Oh!
Please move!
My bit is over.
We can go back to Elmo.
Oh my gosh, I'm shooting, but it's not doing anything!
I'm in danger!
Now there's... Dinosaur fish?
Dolphins?
Oh, we're going in.
No, we're not.
Yes, we are.
Ah!
Please, please, please!
Continue!
Dino dolphins, even.
There's everything you could imagine in this... Oh my gosh.
Please, please, please, please.
Please, please.
This game is so hard.
I wish it were a light gun, honestly.
It would be so much easier.
Oh, I got him, I got him.
Ah!
Oh, I got his ass.
Health!
Shoots everywhere but the health!
Okay, nice.
Yeah, I'm using a controller for this, guys.
There's nothing else.
What else could you use?
I guess a joystick, but...
I don't have one.
Ow!
The birds.
The birds, the birds, the birds.
Pterodactyls, pterodactyls everywhere!
Pterodactyls!
Ow!
Oh my gosh!
This game is brutal.
I mean, it's definitely the sensitivity too, but...
Um...
Hello?
Please, destroy.
Thank you.
DDR pad?
That would be kinda sick, not gonna lie.
Okay.
Ew!
Oh, he sneezed on me!
Oh, how cute!
It's a corner.
Yeah.
Again?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Shoot his head!
Jump up on the hydra's back!
Oh!
Please!
Oh, please!
Thank you for the super chat!
I'm gonna do like five quarters.
Oh, shoot.
Hold on.
Wait.
I was scratching my face.
Oh my god.
How am I supposed to get him to duck back?
Oh my god!
The way he freaks out!
Oh, please.
Please aim.
Please, Watashi!
Aim!
Aim, Watashi!
I'm still shooting, even when he like, comes up like that.
When he comes up like this, but it doesn't do anything.
Are those healths in the...
In the signs up here or something?
Wait, he's almost dead!
He's almost down!
Yay!
I don't think you're supposed to be able to.
We're over to Area 3!
That's so much faster when you like, aren't...
Having to beg for quarters from people.
Oh!
I can't...
Somehow we're alive!
I'm alive!
Raptors, raptors, raptors, raptors!
They're so funny.
Actually...
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
I can't see anything!
Ah!
Everything is just...
Oh god!
The way they pop up is so funny.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
I don't remember this part of the movie.
You guys...
The lava levels?
Oh my gosh, oh my god!
Go away!
Oh, there was help!
Yes, yes.
Are we still in the car?
Yeah!
We are somehow still in the car!
Explode!
Oh my gosh, they're still angry at me?
You guys hold a...
Wait!
Is this the end of the world, or...
Am I crazy?
I don't think there was a volcano in Jurassic Park.
This game is so anxiety-inducing.
Oh, oh!
I'm supposed to shoot these.
Please, please!
Ah!
I can't even see them!
There's so much to keep track of!
Oh my god!
The end of the world is here!
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
I'm the worst driver ever.
Just driving...
Oh, he's showing ass!
No!
I'm missing everything.
You miss 100% of the shots that you do and don't take.
Apparently.
Oh my gosh!
I can't see anything!
Indiana Jones!
Okay, we got two more credits before we have to go back to Elmo.
Everybody tell Elmo what you wanna sing!
What song you wanna hear!
Tell Elmo!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Whoa!
The most dangerous dinosaur rock.
Oh!
Oh, it's...
I was thinking we were playing...
Bowling.
That guy just came up in the middle of the screen.
Oh my gosh!
Die!
Give him one raw... Oh, gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Just dodge!
Just dodge, please!
Sometimes I don't even move my... thing, because I'm like, it's not even... It's not worth it.
Oh, there's so much health!
I missed it!
Oh, this game is insane.
What the hell?
Oh my god!
Please!
We tank those!
This is the last area!
Oh my gosh, we're inside.
Open up.
Oh, ouch.
1HP to dream?
They're like, hi!
The way they come out is so cute.
Oh, they're even upside down!
Clever girl.
No dream.
Now it's just a dream.
Oh my god!
Everybody's inside!
Literally, everybody's here!
The smash of Jurassic...
I can't...
Guys, where is this?
Close, close, close, close, close.
I got a couple.
Oh my god.
Are you guys feeling the pressure?
What a thrill.
What a thrill...
With darkness and silence through the night.
I'm searching and I'll melt into you...
What I fear in my heart, but you're so supreme.
I give my life, not for water, but for you.
Elmo, in my time, there'll be no one else.
Crime, it's the way I find to you.
Elmo, I'm still in a dream.
Elmo.
Someday, you go through the rain.
Someday, you feed on a tree frog.
This ordeal, the trial to survive.
For the day, we see new light.
I give my life, not for honor, but for you.
In my time, there'll be no one else.
It's the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream.
Elmo.
All
right!
We got another quarter!
Let's keep going!
I'm scared.
Plus two.
Oh,
please, please, please, please, please!
I wanna live!
Wait, are we done?
No.
Oh my gosh, this is just like Metal Gear.
Now... Yeah, this is just... This is Metal Gear.
We're escaping.
And Liquid is chasing after us.
Oh!
Liquid!
There's two of them?
I'm getting his butt.
Second guy got his butt.
Got his butt.
Got his butt!
Which one's the real one?
Which one am I supposed to be shooting?
Ah!
Either one!
Two Rexes.
Oh my gosh, you guys, we did that.
We did that, we did that.
Ouch.
Oh, ouch, ouch.
Wait, but I was definitely shooting.
He was not taking any damage.
Good luck.
I
want to mow the lawn again, please.
Let me live, let me live.
Ouch.
Oh my gosh.
Where is he?
Step on it!
Who's driving this thing, actually?
Oh, I am!
Okay.
It's all me, baby!
Oh, he secretly goes back into the forest.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's so close though.
He's taking a lot of damage.
There he goes, there he goes, there he goes, there he goes, there he goes, there he goes!
Wait, why isn't he taking any damage?
His health bar is not going down.
Oh, okay, there it is.
Now it's going.
Come on, come on, come on!
It's quicksand!
I think!
Oh, he's taking a... a nap.
He's... oh, he's smiling!
What did they give him?
Awww...
This might be the biggest quarter, but how could you beat this?
I don't, right?
How?
With many quarters.
The end.
There was never any sequels made for Jurassic Park.
Yahoo!
I pop in and she beats the game.
I'm just too good.
I'm just too...
Not a thought behind those eyes.
He's...
Golly...
Rex looks so derby at the end.
And they say modern gaming is pay to win.
Right!
Golly...
By the way, guys, I have an announcement.
Um...
But...
Thank you, SEGA!
I have an announcement.
But I think I should let Elmo tell this one.
I
have an announcement to make.
would make the announcement after one song.
What should I sing?
Tell me how's Elmo's song to sing.
Wait.
Oh.
Um...
What's Elmo's song?
It's just one of those days where you don't wanna wake up.
Everything is fucked.
Everybody sucks.
You don't really know why.
What you wanna justify.
Ripping someone's head off.
No human contact.
And if you interact, your life is on contract.
Your best bet is to stay away, motherfucker.
It's just one of those days.
It's all about that he says, she says bullshit.
I think you better quit.
Let shit slip.
Or you'll be leaving with a fat lip.
It's all about that he says, she says bullshit.
I think you better quit.
Fuckin' that shit, fuck.
It's just one of those days.
Feelin' like a freight train.
First one to come.
And if you're stuck up, you're just locked up.
Next in line to get fucked up.
Your best bet is to stay away, motherfucker.
It's all about that he says, she says bullshit.
I didn't have the backing vocals on.
It's all about that he says.
Why isn't he saying anything?
I feel like shit.
My suggestion is to keep your distance.
Cause right now I'm dangerous.
We've all felt like shit.
I've been treated like shit.
All those motherfuckers, I wanna step up.
And if my day keeps going this way, I just might break something tonight.
I broke a chainsaw.
I'll skin your ass wrong.
And if my day keeps going this way, I just might break something tonight.
I broke a chainsaw.
I'll skin your ass wrong.
And if my day keeps going this way, I just might break your fucking face tonight.
Give me somethin' to break.
About your fuckin' face.
A chainsaw.
A motherfuckin' chainsaw.
So come and get it.
It's all about the he-says-she-says bullshit.
I think you better quit like Chisnip or you'll be leaving with a fat lip.
I think you better quit talking that shit, huh?
So come and get it.
Yay!
Elmo says new outfit day.
Come see it.
Woof woof.
Yay!
Yeah.
Um, I guess it's kind of a short stream today.
I still have my migraine, actually.
So I think I'm gonna... Um, I knew it would be kind of short today.
I wanted to take it a bit easy after...
after yesterday.
Since yesterday was such a busy day for me!
But, um, yes!
Uh, uh, new outfit!
Next Saturday.
Hmm.
I hope you guys had fun with my- with me collecting my, um, it was my, uh, uh, my fetch quest and- and- and- and Jurassic Park Arcade!
Wimsy!
Thank you so much for the five gift, dude!
Thanks for the silly stream!
New outfit hype!
Yeah!
Oh, gosh.
My throat is still- like I said, I woke up this morning, my throat was so bad because of the- the air!
And- maybe also flying, too.
Like, the air in- in- on the planes is also so dry.
And I flew twice in one day, so... Thanks for the fun stream of funny bits!
Thank you!
Otsubito, everybody!
I'll see you guys- well, tomorrow.
And if I don't see you tomorrow, I'll definitely- I will see you!
I- I will make the- the- the- the waiting room for the new outfit.
Well, actually, I have to wait for- I've made this- I made it kind of ugly.
I have to wait for the artist to make a nice version that says the actual date.
Thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you!
Otsubito!
Thank you!
Having done that sort of Elmo voice myself, I know it's a stray and- oh!
It's not- it wasn't at all!
Did I shine?
Thank you, guys!
Thank you- oh!
I forgot.
Everybody...
Your quarter...
From me...
To you...
Church...
Cherish it.
Weeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee!
Ha ha ha ha ha!